I got an interesting phone call yes ed I
want to share with you that may give you
some perspective I'm at the office right
now I just got back from San Antonio in
Atlanta my baby girl just wanted to be
with me came to the office but she
knocked that on the way because she's
sleeping right now let me take about the
call I got yesterday yesterday one of my
associates that works but the scry
Thomas sends me a text message saying
this man here whom he just met he says
he trained you when you were new in
sales is this true
I said send me the picture he sends me a
picture I look at the picture I said
absolutely he did he says do you have a
minute we got on the phone I said Cisco
how you doing
Cisco's will Cisco as my general manager
when I first started working with Bally
Total Fitness Culver City years ago I
don't even know what it was 99 when I
got out of the Army probably August
September of 99 when I started working
there and he says hey man how you doin
how's everything he said I laugh at this
right now incredible guy incredible guy
who he was and he says Pat I run into so
many people from phbm from value Tim and
all the stuff and every time I tell him
I trained you they don't believe me I
said well Cisco is the truth you did you
you got me to stay in the sales business
so let me explain to you exactly what he
did I think there's a lot to learn here
because either you're gonna be Cisco
having Patricks in your life or you
gonna relate to me having a Cisco on
your life both ways someone's gonna
relate to this story so I start working
on Bally's and he's training me and he's
very calm very encouraging very calm
challenges but it's very common egos can
coexist around this guy and one month
into the business okay I'm working our
bellies I have sold a whopping zero
memberships after being at Bally's
Culver City for one month I go to Cisco
at Cisco listen he says what I said look
I'm one of the most insane cuz in here
the only guy that's more in shape than I
am out of the sales guys is dextra I'm
in shape I look good I work out I know
more about weightlifting and nutrition
all this stuff than any of these guys
here but man I just can't sell
membership man sales isn't for me it
says Patrick you were made for sales
this is this guy on why you're saying
this I'm not a good sales guy
Patrick do you trust me I said I trust
you he says here's what I want you to do
I so what's that he says I don't want
you to sell memberships at the gym
anymore I said what do you owe me to
sell memberships he said I want you to
go to Fox Hills Mall which Fox Hills
Mall is like Culver City area he says I
want you to go sell memberships in the
mall and test that out for one month I
said I said let me get this straight
Cisco I can't sell memberships in the
gym with all the equipment here the
weights here the classes here the sauna
here you want me to sell memberships in
a mall where there's nothing there you
want me to go do that
he said yes just trust me on this I said
I don't think this is gonna work here to
make a difference he said just do it so
I go to the mall Fox's mom so I like
Cisco I said I'm gonna do it no problem
I go to the mall and there was this
escalator in fact so small and we would
set up a booth like imagine a table like
this covered with a black cloth you know
what I'm talking about right and I would
stand literally right behind it because
I didn't want to go around and talk to
people that are walking in front of me
at the mall because I was so nervous and
shy and worried about what if they yeah
Prospect and I said no we're not in
China concerned a little bit because I'm
this guy big ego got out of the military
you don't tell me no you don't reject me
so but there was three other guys that
were selling and I was watching them and
oh yeah you don't grow honey don't I you
know Sam I talked about Bally Total
Fitness and all this stuff right so
finally I'm like trying to talk to
people I would say hey would you would
you and they would walk off I'd say hey
excuse me excuse me can I get kit and
boom they would walk up I did this for a
couple hours nothing happened
next thing you know I came across and I
came to the edge of my table and I stood
right here a little bit closer to people
but still safe because I'm touching the
table then excuse me excuse me then
finally I came a little bit here closer
then I started talking to the police
one lady finally said yes Bally's Cobra
said yes
what are you right I said come over here
she comes
she sits down I'm sitting down here she
sits down right next to me at the table
I said uh yes have you been to the gym
before I have would you like to have a
membership yes the laziest questions you
could ask somebody that has no clue to
us she says yeah I'd like to buy a
membership from you I said you you would
like to buy a membership for me right
now yes right now yes how much iterates
seventy-five down 40 a month corporate
rate okay no problem here's my credit
card I you own about right now yes I
wanna buy it right now
you know what's 36 month contract I know
I want to buy it right now um okay mr.
Baida membership right now so I'm
nervous I'm feeling get out I've never
filled a contract before with Bally's
and it was a contract got to give a
printout because it's a 36 month
contract I'm filling it out and I'm
nervous the other three guys are looking
at me she says great gives me the credit
card information I call Cisco Cisco what
somebody just bought a membership from
me
you gotta be kidding me no I told you
Pat I told you Pat you were made with
this Pat you were made to sell Cisco's
telling me this never forgive this
conversation he said Pat go so um more
today go go talk to more people look
what you could do today I went I saw
three more a month later under Rookie of
the Month a quarter later the smallest
gym in Bally's Culver City in a basement
it smelled it was not the most sexy gym
that they have but the team was the
sickest best team we had Cisco Joe Danny
Ruben Dexter Gino Silvio
I mean delay we have Donna we had to
bask what next we had the best squad
Sean all of us sickest squad we had
right we all got along we've got we work
we were good together
then next thing you know I'm seven
quarter later were triple crown triple
crown is if you're number one in
nutritionals number one and personal
training and number one in sales we want
triple crown back to back and Cisco was
the manager and I left I got a promotion
went to another gym in an obviously
years late I continue I go to do
financial services and the rest is
history and Craig Thomas calls me and
says
want to talk to Cisco I talked to Cisco
and in that conversation
I just went back 20 years 20 I was 20
years old when I worked for Cisco I went
back 21 years okay think about this guy
what does that story have to do with you
you know some of you may have somebody
on your team that's kind of like Patrick
bid David rough-around-the-edges
military maybe athlete may be a tough
guy maybe a big ego guy maybe big ego
yet at the same time his ego is so you
know like crystal it can break if
somebody hurts it cuz that's what this
kid was this guy was all military tough
call this stuff in it's like a persona
but at the same time he doesn't know if
he can sell he just wants to go out and
find some kind of money I'm about to
join the army I'm going back into the
army because it systems not working on
I'm telling sis coming to go back into
the army and Cisco says Pat I believe in
you you can do sales and look what
happens to this guy by the way there's
about 10 Cisco's in my life one day I'm
gonna list all these names for people
know who these people are my life and
the kind of impact they made but he was
one of the biggest ones because he
kick-started my career I'd never worked
a sales job
he was my first sales manager and he
treated me gently he believed in me he
coached me it was patient with me he
challenged me he wasn't afraid of me he
wasn't afraid to say hey you can't sell
over here guess what go sell on the mall
and shadow three other people and see
what they're gonna be doing you'll learn
I can't sell memberships here it doesn't
matter I'm gonna put you in a tougher
place because if you can hang there for
the rest of your life you're gonna learn
how to feed yourself because you have to
generate customers there you're not
waiting for people to come to the gym
you're going to them you changed my life
I say this to you because either be a
Cisco or if you got a Cisco on your life
respond to the challenge they give you
to be a Patrick either way pick one of
those two because at the end of the day
if that doesn't happen I'm going back
into the army and when I go back into
the army I would have retired three
years ago two and a half years ago with
a retired okay with $3,000 a month I
would've done 20 years in the army
because I had given up in the civilian
life that's what I would say civilian
life is not for me I'm a military guy
this close to go to my 20 they would
never been by attainment that would have
never been PHP they would have never
been in
surance agency that would have never
been to three kids I have there would
have never been all these other stories
never I would have just been a regular
guy your story
is this close to just being a regular
person this close between being a
regular person in this clothes for the
world to know your last name we're
legacies being left behind and sometimes
you got to listen to the people around
you because for many years I was afraid
of praying as a kid because I used to go
to an Assyrian Church in Iran and the
pastor would say God is so powerful if
you pray he will answer your prayer but
he is so powerful he's so mighty and I
like dude I don't want to pray this guy
answers my prayers voices gonna be deep
hey Patrick how do you know it was like
I'm a six-year-old kid I don't want to
pray in your round what if this God you
know person comes and prays so but later
on you know even as an atheist later on
in my life I looked at the way God
answered my prayers through other people
Hafiz once said I can't say the exact
words but he says God uses people as a
fruit to speak their words to us it's
just on us to catch the words that are
coming to us maybe this is a message for
you this morning to realize either be a
Cisco or go lift the next Patrick's in
your life and you'll be life-changing
because for the rest of your life you
can look back and say I made an impact
in the world because Cisco did on what
he did with this 20 year old Patrick and
obviously I did because I listened to
his challenge and I responded to his
challenge and I took the initiative and
the rest is history I hope you take
something away from this message having
said that guys let's have a killer week
this week if you haven't subscribed to
the channel do so love you take care of
buh bye
you
[Music]